[Music]
stop it
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was
after having a child i realize there's
nothing more important than
julie bowen wrote love and support
piers morgan wrote sacrifice and
devotion
kanye west wrote kanye west
[Applause]
sometimes without any planning at all i
tom hanks wrote go on vacation
will arnett wrote head to the beach
nicholas cage wrote make all my movies
justin bieber peeing in a mop bucket was
kristen chenoweth wrote one misstep by a
misguided kid
nick offerman wrote another obnoxious
incident from a spoiled brat justin
bieber wrote a precursor to next month's
crap in a vacuum cleaner
looking forward to that my hidden talent
is
gwyneth paltrow wrote juggling charlie
day wrote wiggling my ears
bruce jenner wrote using my face as a
snare drum
[Applause]
excellent
when i
when i heard what paula dean said about
black people i thought aaron paul wrote
she used terrible judgment
jennifer lawrence wrote she should know
better
mumford and sons wrote what are black
people
[Applause]
my eyes are
alec baldwin wrote blue
halle berry wrote hazel
chris christie wrote up here
[Applause]
i was once thrown out of a party for
seth rogen wrote being too rowdy
aziz ansaria wrote making fun of the
host
chris brown wrote misunderstanding a
sign that said punchbowl
[Music]
i lend my face to
angelina jolie wrote international
women's causes
ted danson wrote environmental causes
mickey rourke wrote children's
nightmares
it's just on loan just
gotta give it back gotta give it back
kids you gotta give it back and finally
on the very first date we jack mcbreyer
wrote went bowling
jennifer aniston wrote went to a movie
larry king wrote slithered onto land
primordial i think